[Musik]
es ist ein wunderschöner tag hier in
köln wer mit rausgucken wir sehen schon
die sonne scheint komplett ich weiß
nicht wann der sommer endlich mal endet
mittlerweile 40 gesagt ein bisschen auf
jeden fall auch jetzt noch einen ganz
ganz schönen guten morgen an meinen
besten freund ich werde dass er
gleichzeitig mein einziger freund das
ist dave davis fotograf und bearbeitet
bei der instagram bilde ich bin denn ich
bin fotograf und war das übrigens jona
der geschlafen hat und was im heutigen
loch so passieren wird meine damen und
her eigentlich gar nichts im leben ist
langweilig wie scheiß hast kannst du
heute passiert allerdings ein bisschen
was uns war es gerade die gamescom in
köln
das heißt über alles statt wie sonst was
habe ich denn die heute nicht vielleicht
haben wir doch noch kurz zur gamescom
aber das ist erst mal nicht primär das
ziel für heute sondern ich habe bei der
wohnung eine riesige zwesten problem
immer wenn ich irgendwas zu essen der
stelle kommen 40 besten 30 zeugen
jehovas an und ich brauche halt
irgendetwas damit ich die loswerde und
ich dachte mir hey weil ich gesund
meinte juncker schnelle kakaopulver eine
schale und sind das an
also ich hab ja es hat wer hat gesagt
ich habe keinen bock ihm eine wohnung
hat abzufangen deswegen hab ich mir
gedacht hier einfach eine
fleischfressende pflanze er ist die
teilenummern venusfliegenfalle dank an
julius biologie kenntnisse
und es gibt verschiedene arten von
fleischfressende pflanze das geht nicht
beispielsweise hier
sonne satt zehn jahre sowie dieses
pokémon
es gibt karnivoren es gibt die
venusfliegenfalle es gibt eine
schlauchpflanze also alles so
verschieden aber ich finde die sieht
eigentlich schon am meisten aus wir
fahren jetzt erst mal ein baumarkt
[Musik]
meine sehr verehrten damen und herren
sind angekommen im obi das ist eine
kiste kritiker allerdings nicht sondern
wir sind auf der suche nach venus
fliegen fallen sehen wir sind nicht
unbedingt gefallen aber ohne sarrazin
muss also nach einfach pflanzen die
tiere essen
das sieht genauso aus wie seit zehn
jahre von pokémon egal was geht also wir
haben mit der ubi mitarbeiterin
gesprochen jemand wir dürfen hier keine
menschen filmen wegen der datenschutz
krams dingsbums aber hier sind keine
menschen hier sind pflanzen wir testen
jetzt mal ob die pflanze überhaupt
funktionieren wir brauchen also ich würd
sagen wir kaufen eine kleine pflanze und
einmal sonne hätte die sache ist wie
kriegen wir die denn jetzt mit
nein dieses platzes umgefallen ich weiß
nicht was wir hier machen wir haben
gerade einfach für 25 euro 2 so fliegen
fressende pflanzen gekauft das ding ist
dass die eine pflanzliche auf der einen
seite so ein bisschen für welt bis davon
ist man deswegen werden wir
wahrscheinlich nachher kannibalismus
betreiben und die pflanze mit dem
eigenen abend führt
wir fahren jetzt nach hause
wir sind zurück zu hause angekommen
damen und herren und nicht nur 420 und
ich und die beiden pflanzen sondern wir
waren noch eine menge menge obst und so
einkaufen wer jetzt einen obstsalat
machen bzw
jedoch soll es ja nicht um diesen
obstsalat gehen sondern um diese beiden
wunderschön eigentlich können wir damit
vor dem kurzbahn pflanzenpollen machen
hier vorne schön die beiden
fleischfressenden pflanzen und die
brauchen einfach noch ein bisschen
wasser also die beiden pflanzen damit
hier unten wasser drin die brauchen mich
die ganze zeit wasser unten
damit sie überleben können und ich finds
echt krass das sieht genauso aus wie
seit zehn jahren hier habe ich das mal
an der eins zu eins einfach sehen ja das
ding ist diese pflanze heiß oder sarah
zehn jahre und die sich hier heißt
venusfliegenfalle das ding ist dass man
hier allerdings nicht einfach ein
stechen darf die wo hier ist sie einfach
schon zu gehören man darf dadurch alter
dies auch schon hier zugegangen und hier
die ist wieso hatten die wahl schon so
etwas gefressen
man darf da nicht einfach so insinger
reinstecken so wie man das als kind
immer gemacht hat weil das ist
eigentlich alles schlecht für die
pflanzen
da fliegt halt 'ne fliege rein und dann
weist die quasi zu und dann haben sie
nur essen wenn sich die fliege da
drinnen noch weiter bewegt weil dadurch
lebt diese 250 verkauft und dadurch wird
die pflanze angeregt bevor wir uns
allerdings und das festmahl dieser
beiden schönheiten kümmern werden wir
uns jetzt erst mal etwas können leckerer
salat lebten wieder auf jeden fall haben
wir gerade den instagram account von
dieter bohlen entdeckt ich sag euch mal
was selber so hoch lädt schönes
wochenende verbringen ich freue mich
wahnsinnig wenn du nicht falsch ich
schöne bilder von mali auf keinen fall
wieder senden die todo gesicht damals
allerdings würde ich sagen wir testen
jetzt mal unsere kleinen pflänzchen hier
fordert also ich habe tatsächlich noch
eine kleine weste hier gefunden die lag
da hinten auf so eine ablage und die
würde ich sagen verfüttern was man die
pflanze die sache ist es eigentlich
nicht so gutes und dass man wieder die
inhalt lebendige sachen geben sollte ich
kann jetzt keine lebendige dem
verzauberten der finale moment in meinem
leben freundlich dass sie jetzt die
wespe eben diese fliegenfalle fallen um
mein gott wenn ihr das essen
hallo die dazu groß also hier vorne ist
diese wespe drin im juli versucht die
pflanze kader nochmals ein bisschen zu
reizen weil dadurch dann dass die
konzentrierte dritt oder viert sie das
dann halt so richtig hin zu verdauen und
so weiter
warum diese anderen auch schon zugesagt
sind aber die soll irgendwie wird die
das nicht so wirklich essen
ich würde sagen dass wir bei dieser
pflanze oder diesem prozess hier mit der
vespa ackermann tag abwarten bzw ihr den
fortschritt da dem nächsten blog seht
also der kommt er dann ermorden und dann
schon noch die feste tot ist oder ob
diese platte welver welt ist und
gestorben ist allerdings dass sie
natürlich nicht die einzige pflanze die
bei uns gekauft haben sondern wir haben
ja hier noch den mega boss die fed nicht
gefällt mir die sache ist spd das ist
halt das ding hier na ja die zeit hier
schon verwenden und damit für diese hier
jetzt nicht noch eine wespe doch die
haben doch mal beweist das ist eine
richtig fette halte die sache dass da
hinten halten finden ihrem 38 und
deswegen sind da halt immer so richtig
wie der westen und kupfer die hier die
seit fast so groß wie dieser nicht
wahrscheinlich auch telefon zu hause
schaute den anfang machen die sind ja
auch schon so breit oder soll es ist
richtig fette mine gewesen weil sie es
ja tot deswegen würde ich sagen
funktioniert das mit dieser szene
eigentlich also da kommt die jetzt hier
bin ich ein spaß die alter bin ich dumm
2000 jahre später so leute die beste ist
drin
die diesmal noch vom mittelrhein
aber schließt sie sich jetzt hatten wir
fordern deswegen kann mir die
reingepackt wie es wirklich direkten bis
nach ganz unten hier durchgerutscht die
sache ist nur die pflanze bewegt sich
bisher noch nicht das sieht auch alles
nicht so richtig aus diese befestigung
von diesen also das ding funktioniert
bisher irgendwie nicht so gleich fünfmal
daneben und stecker einstecken ja leute
wir haben hier diese sa 10 ja die hat
jetzt da unten so eine weste drin und
wir haben hier die venusfliegenfalle die
hat jetzt eine biene halterin an die
genfer dauert also ich würde sagen im
nächsten block gebe ich euch dann update
was mit den beiden hier passiert ist
schreibt man namen für die beiden
kleinen helden die kommentare
allerdings werden wir uns jetzt nicht
weiter mit diesen pflanzen beschäftigen
sondern wie gesagt nächsten woche kommt
dem update leute sondern wir gehen jetzt
in eine war zusammen mit dave und jona
um ilja und alex und vielen andern
leuten diese balance jahrgangs sind so
schrecklich
eigentlich wollten wir in so einer ruft
vorbeigehen
die ist da oben irgendwo die war aber
komplett voll deswegen immer zu ihr ja
und so hat alles gut ist wegen dem
erzähler und so ein brauhaus
das ist manager ilja der mich jetzt
einfach die ganze zeit komplett
ignoriert hast du dich bei mir
entschuldigen was 28 9
es geht nicht ja es richtig wir haben
zwar gehört schon was gegessen habe
aber ich habe genau die aufnahme gerade
schon mal gewitzelt
wir sind jetzt auch offen sondern party
im alten wartesaal dahinten hier
übrigens eine kirche das ding ist
gelaufen gerade so einfach über die
straße und de facto ja da vorne ist dass
er okay und dann läuft der wirklich
farbigen land und läuft dem hoteleingang
nur dass bushido und so stehen also
schon lustig gerade auf jeden fall
jemals feiern
partie
es war cool viele andere youtuber
wiederzusehen vor allem auch mit dem
habe ich ganz viele tolle ins netz
stellt videos bilder gemacht
[Musik]
quality content die sache ist allerdings
auch als wir von dem pflanzen venus
fliegen geschehen wenn auch die sache
ist allerdings auch als wir vom obi
zurückgefahren sind nach hause sind ja
eigentlich gar nicht erst zu mir
gefallen sondern wir waren noch
basketball spielen und da habe ich auch
noch videos meine story gehauen
[Musik]
ich bin auch basketball profi auf jeden
fall den wir jetzt hier fahren taxi
genau mit der polizei vor mir zurück als
das foto von mir vom polizei auf jeden
fall fahren jetzt nach hause und gehen
schlafen also wenn euch der woche hat
das geld noch ein like da das mit für
taxi driver männlich dieser druck
gefallen hat was gerne ein leih klar wir
fahren jetzt nach hause und ja ich
schreibe mir die kommentare wie alt ihr
seid jetzt wirklich interessieren ich
bin 67
[Musik]